woher kommen eigentlich die vielen
multiresistenten keime bisher war man
davon ausgegangen dass die weltweit
durch die verbreitete verwendung von
antibiotika verursacht werden
zu viele antibiotika in tierfutter das
zu frühe absetzen der medikamente
wodurch die gefährlichsten keime
überleben antibiotika die ins
trinkwasser geraten und so weiter jetzt
aber scheint sich herauszustellen dass
ein ort auf der welt dafür die größte
verantwortung trägt wieder rabatt in
indien dort leiten die farmer fabriken
nämlich sowie die produktionsrückstände
aus der antibiotika produktion in
einfluss dass dort eine art bioreaktor
für multiresistente erreger unter freien
himmel entstanden ist jetzt wirklich zum
zweiten sind herzlich willkommen
manche nachrichten lassen einfach
ziemlich fassungslos da stehen diese ist
so eine und west mich daran zweifeln ob
wir als menschen in der lage wenn hier
auf der erde zu überleben egal ob
atomkraft abholzung bewegen weil es und
jetzt dass wir wegen echt ziemlich
konzentriert an dem ast auf dem wir
sitzen forscher des
universitätsklinikums leipzig haben die
gewässer in hüde rabatt in indien vor
ort untersucht und 23 proben rund um
pharma fabriken genommen all diesen
proben seien antibiotika rückstände und
pilzmittel gefunden worden die
grenzwerte seien zum teil um das 1000
fache überschritten worden es wurde auch
direkt eine gegenprobe durch das
institut für biomedizinische und
pharmazeutische forschung gemacht auch
die forscherinnen und forscher fanden in
16 proben rückstände von medikamenten
christoph schubert vom
universitätsklinikum leipzig ist
alarmiert er findet diese ergebnisse
beängstigen unter freiem himmel war hier
ein bioreaktor für multiresistente keime
entstanden das ist die globalisierung
der erreger die multiresistenten
bakterien haben sich von dort schon weit
verbreitete mehr als 70 prozent aller
indien touristen bringen
solche keime mit nach hause sind die
folgen der drastischen kostensenkungen
in der pharmaindustrie auf deutsche
medikamenten hersteller produzieren
antibiotika nicht mehr selbst auch sie
lassen ihre antibiotika die meisten
jedenfalls
in liederbach produzieren eine der
letzten antibiotika produktion in europa
in frankfurt wurde 2016 geschlossen wäre
also möglich
die medikamente auch so zu produzieren
mit europäischen standards für unsere
erde nicht mit multiresistenten keimen
überfluten aber die gewinnmaximierung
der pharmaindustrie verursacht jetzt
einen weltweiten medizinischen notstand
15.000 menschen sterben jedes jahr in
den krankenhäusern in deutschland
nachgewiesen an multiresistenten
erregern
experten gehen von einer hohen
dunkelziffer tatsächlich 50.000 toten
aus weltweit sind es 700 tausend
mediziner rechnen mit zehn millionen
toten pro jahr im jahr 2050 damit
bewegen wir uns im bereich der
krebstoten jedes jahr
ich finde ziemlich furchtbar sollen
pharmaunternehmen eigentlich dafür
sorgen
dass wir gesund werden und über wieder
rabatt in indien verbreiten die los
schlimme erreger die schon bald für
millionen tote verantwortlich sein
können das ist wirklich furchterregend
und die reaktionen sind jetzt leider
etwas verhalten
bundesgesundheitsminister herrmann gröhe
mahnend international geltende industrie
und umweltstandards an der bundesverband
der pharmazeutischen industrie will
jetzt stärker auf die einhaltung
vereinbarter umweltrichtlinien einwirken
dass wir jetzt alle so als ob es noch
jahre dauert bis wir das in den griff
bekommen ich bin wirklich etwas ratlos
jetzt sind es von 700.000 pro jahr
da muss doch sofort gehandelt werden wie
der rabatt ist mit diesen auswirkungen
doch schlimmer als tschernobyl oder
fukushima ich bin gespannt ob letztlich
vielleicht doch die politik mal wach
wird und hier schnell und weltweit
reagiert und die produktion dort sofort
stoppt bis standards eingehalten werden
die millionen tote weltweit vielleicht
noch verhindern ich halte euch die auf
jeden fall auf dem laufenden wenn also
nicht zu diesem thema hier verpassen
wollt dann solltet ihr ein abo aufs auge
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke dann
verpasst er auch garantiert kein video
hier die gesamten weiteren zukunfts
thema smart home und wie es unser leben
verändert also mal etwas positives
einfach draufklicken und so geht es
weiter und ansonsten bislang bleibt dran